this year a lot of us are focused on
having good clean healthy fun right so
how about a plant-based sunday brunch
lindsay and miles founders of the edible
bunch are here to explain that they've
partnered with starbase to bring this
unique brunch experience to town thank
you thank you happy new year happy new
year to you okay so first off just
explain the edible bunch what do you
guys do
so basically the edible bunch is here to
bring plant-based food and we just want
to show people that you don't have to
sacrifice anything that you use or used
to with animal based meals i love that i
love that and you guys are bringing this
brunch experience because you know
brunch is supposed to be fun it's
supposed to be lit but you can also make
it healthy and keep the lip parts
doing both okay so how are we doing it
so for one we're going to have our hosts
asia jade and uh dizzy wright recording
there will be entertainment live
entertainment also by uh alex stabler
from um the winds lovre okay we're also
going to have djd money from 97.5 as a
dj
and we have some other fun things going
on as well okay so this is all happening
on sundays but not this is a limited
time experience right so the first one
will be january 16th okay um and if you
want to find out our other dates you can
just tap into
starbaselv.com okay all right so let's
talk about the food now because i see
her
i am finishing up our original recipe
steak it will be featured on our meat
and potato station okay it comes with
tofu scrambled and a potato melody and
there is no meat here no our meat is
made out of chickpeas we make this
in-house our original recipe we also
have our french toast over here this is
caramelized type with a
fresh berry compote and a coconut cream
and a beet root powdered sugar so i just
finished up this steak oh it smells so
good i wish you guys were here to taste
it me too but also not really because i
want it all to myself
okay and while you're playing while
you're preparing that tell us um
tell us more about starbase itself this
is an event space right so yes starbase
is in the hybrid event space and what i
mean by that is every time you walk in
starbase for uh
for an actual event it's gonna look
different it's gonna be customized to
that event
wow okay so when people walk in what is
what are they going to see
when they walk in it's it's really going
to be a sensory overload i'm going to be
honest with you yes we first are going
to have a charcuterie station when you
first walk in and then you can't do
brunch without your creator no you can
right it is all vegan it's going to be
all vegan items on there then we're
going to open up the rest of the space
to our french toast station our macaroni
and cheese station which is all vegan as
well and then our meat potato station
you'll be able to collide and network
and talk and eat and just have this
reimagined event space bring you in and
just love plant-based sundays wow okay
so while i taste this yeah there's some
specials that you guys need to share to
some promos yes yes health
or heal by myself
now if you go to the actual event right
or you go to the
to the website of starbase and you put
in heal thyself you'll get 20 percent
off your tickets right wow
okay okay so they should go ahead and
get their tickets now now
why not yeah take advantage of the promo
code go ahead another piece i have to
tell you
okay tell us one more time what we're
eating this is our filled steak right
here this is our original recipe it's
made out of chickpeas our own special
spice blend as well and with our
original recipe marinade this is
delicious and i heard there's a raffle
there is bottles yeah so yes the raffle
actually the proceeds from the raffle
will actually go to heaven can wait
it's a non-kill animal shelter so
please join in for the raffle because
i'm sure that we are eating good we're
having fun and we're giving back we
can't ask for anything better than that
thank you guys thank you for having us
we really appreciate it